[Music]
and no tip news submitted by JK tour at
my school's okay what is that like a JK
high school tour oh okay we're a
university school oh I'm gonna go and
say that's sure they won't do University
tour be even worse man I'm gonna do it
you need trigger warnings yeah exactly
trigger warning the whole time triggered
everything just get a shirt that says
trigger warning and you're constantly
covered there you go
a waitress was fired after complaining
on social media about getting stiffed on
a tip by a church group oh here's a tip
go to church that's what they might say
is it because she was of the scissoring
nature or the sword fighting nature oh I
guess she's probably like LGBT yeah is
she gay LGBT [ __ ] LGBTQA I don't know
what's the details alright girl her name
is Tam Lin she's 25 years old I said oh
really yeah so she works at Outback and
oh well then tick Australian outback a
spec house I got food poisoning for that
place yeah please terrible I only ate
that once I got [ __ ] up
you have a boom you have a bloomin onion
there dude and anything else and it's
like you've eaten enough for like a
month
they give you so much close to the
awesome blossom at Chili's I think it's
the same journey I love that Ange it's
nuts man yeah it's like 2,000 calories a
bite I know what a California enforced
that law were chain restaurants have to
put the caloric content of their food
yeah I didn't realize that at Chili's I
ate 4,000 calories and what's different
dude that to it that's what killed
Chili's yeah who killed Chile's cuz
Chili's used to be filled with the brim
before that I used to get this like
applewood smoked bacon burger and some
fries and that [ __ ] was like thirty nine
hundred calories whole including the
[ __ ] coke that I drank and that was
already the third meal of day so it's
like cigarette warnings yeah it's like
just leave me alone
only friends cigarette you ain't gonna
put a picture of a dead baby on the
cover of it like let me smoke the
freaking cigarette yeah while she was
working on that back they got a huge
order it was a seven hundred and thirty
five dollar takeout order placed by this
church here they ordered 25 steaks 25
chickens and 25 potatoes 25 the number
wait it's a takeout order
I never tipped I won't give it a go who
takes steak for two for take-out yeah
take outs are kind of that I'm not too
sure about the tipping on TLC yes that's
kind of so she was saying that as
servers they make low wage and but this
entire [ __ ] like her entire shift she
took up most of that time to prepare
this one order and she didn't get a tip
for that order so she was upset she
vented on Facebook one of her male
friends saw that post and told her to
delete it and he told her he would call
the church about the incident like he's
gonna get her back yeah no that's no I
think he was like let me solve the issue
like a lawyer and help you out and
hopefully I get some [ __ ] later I
wonder if that guy's in love with her
exactly mediator i'ma do you this favor
suck my dick later cos this [ __ ]
church out for you yeah so then the
church ended up contacting the
restaurant to make amends and the
restaurant gave the church a full refund
on the order after finding out that she
posted negatively about it on Facebook
and they fired her because it is in
their policy that employees cannot post
about customers on social media that guy
did not get [ __ ] I got this babe right
I got fired
yeah and so the church ended up
contacting her and compensated her for
though that's really nice of the church
yeah there is nothing in the Bible about
tipping yeah saying that usually like
because they'll do it a lot of takeout
orders but this particular instance they
had a volunteer go pick up the order and
that volunteer they shouldn't even have
to explain the church was just saying
that they usually tip really well but
that this volunteer didn't know the
church is tipping practice
and so this church tips on take-out I've
heard of this church there's a probably
nice kid it was pickup so if they went
and drove and picked it up why the [ __ ]
would you get a tip that's what I mean
it's not it was delivery you don't get a
tip well I guess we've learned something
new like they're actually getting pooled
from you know tables because they're
preparing a huge order yeah because she
was saying that she only made $18 that
big yeah I mean it depends on the
restaurant
but the hold on oh yeah yeah where I
worked the hosts do get tips but it's
it's always way less than you know the
people at the tables and it's I always
thought it was not the same like it's
optional for me to even working in a
restaurant all that I don't even feel
like takeout you should or or I mean not
take out but yeah pick up you should tip
hell nah never literally ever tipping on
being served like when you sit on a
table they're [ __ ] running [ __ ] for
you all that stuff even at Jersey Mike's
rent and go get a dress and Mike's thing
and it's always like hey you want a tip
and I'm always like no I love Jersey
Mike's loved Jersey Mike's do you tip
depending yeah depending eggs net for me
I only tip at the one that I normally
frequent because we have a connect you
know that makes sense
and they'll hook it up right then it's
like well bro here you go you know I tip
if they don't do a song or [ __ ] ring
a bell or something if you leave me
alone while I tip I'll do it but if you
if you gotta make it a big [ __ ] thing
I don't want to do dirty Mike's makes
the most sense to tip at any sandwich
spot because you see them slice the
whole [ __ ] there yeah subway there
that's our job man that's the [ __ ]
job do not [ __ ] analyze I actually
get them every time yeah I mean that's
what I was thinking too I'm like yeah
you're preparing this takeout order I
mean I mean yeah you're gonna be doing
that regardless I mean why do you need
it for that I don't know people are just
making like voluntary things like
mandatory now let me get all upset and I
don't like how she went on Facebook
doing air off all this bad news and then
I think that's Karma the church of all
places yeah it's like I'll tip my
postmates person depending so we have a
condo there you have to enter a game
code and go up they don't if they don't
come up
ten millions that have you know go up
those but I tip very well if you do know
I'd like a guy just comes up and he just
like the last guy came up he goes oh oh
oh your orders here I was like cool I
was like here's the gate code anything
goes
what can you come down and get it I said
why don't let the way you talk to me all
right cool
went down he wasn't me outside of his
car he just has like one star [ __ ] no
tip this lady do that to me I used or -
I'll never use the service again this
lady had me come out of my apartment go
to the frickin like curb and then she
drove up it's the same way only post
myths I've noticed they can yeah but you
get my compensated well you know I mean
I'm talking about if my orders like 20
bucks I'll give you like five six bucks
if you went up [ __ ] Mordor to come to
me I understand I tip sometimes based
off of how poor they look I feel sorry
for you the chick is attractive I have
noticed that I will usually do more true
you don't want a girlfriend why cuz you
don't get no tip it's not about that
it's it's something stupid with me where
I'm like I want her to know that I'm
doing pretty good just let you take care
of ya I'm not like it's not like I'm
like oi you know later on maybe down the
road no it's like for my own stupid
[ __ ] man American food service and I
was always like [ __ ] salty toward the
hot girl waitresses that would [ __ ]
get all this money for no goddamn reason
because I know that I look at them and I
go you know good-looking dudes getting
good good tip too bad yeah I [ __ ] tip
good-looking dudes for some reason -
it's like it's like the human I don't
know what it is do it like the more
attractive you are the better people are
there poor as [ __ ] you need this if
they're ugly as [ __ ] you need this it's
good opposite if the guy's not even
good-looking but he's got a cute bottle
tip
actually slide it into the back of his
pants cute Chippendales sir it's not
that type of establishment well you have
a cute ass
yeah I liked it can't get tip quite
place I just want to say you're the cute
ass thank you
I didn't realize like how important
tipping was until later just because
like I feel like my parents never really
- yeah restaurants yeah it wasn't really
that big of a thing you know because
like in Korea - you don't tip so my
parents don't understand tipping culture
here so I didn't know about that [ __ ]
and I was like oh am I supposed to tip
but I didn't until I actually started
making dude I couldn't wait to serve
white people like oh oh my customers I'm
gonna wait their table because like if
it's you know the tipping culture is way
different if you show I mean like they
they take into consideration like the
ambiance everything your service how
much you make them laugh how well you
explain the [ __ ] menu like they'll
sometimes tip a hundred percent of their
bill so if it's a hundred bucks the
[ __ ] tip a hundred bucks whoa
yeah see I don't like when people expect
tips when is it this is based on service
so you get tip based on how good your
services yeah you don't get tip just
because you threw water in my face I
mean like if you came up and you just
did your job like you [ __ ] hated it
you're not gonna get a tip I thought
entertainment that make you laugh today
[ __ ] what did you sound like
because I can't picture you as a server
for that client health what do you mean
like what do you sound like well cuz
remember I was so much more ghetto back
then yeah so I was like have you all had
sushi before check this out that's a
yeah I'll be like salmon you look like a
sign of person BAM you you what do you
like sir I I I did that like yeah yeah
all right boy I'll be back dad oh my god
shoo I got you you have that water code
and it always always sneak out [ __ ]
like salad I'm not supposed to do this
for you guys but here check it out salad
salad check it out yeah watch guys
[ __ ] myself curse I love it I would
do that at Cheesecake Factory I'd be
like hey I'm not supposed to do this but
here's the brand yet they love that they
love it dude you give up an extra
everyone's always happy as hell yeah
like really all things I'm not even
gonna charge you man you guys are
special okay cuz you know what we talked
for 35 seconds and like I think you guys
are cool I always love that you know no
I'm saying I would do that if I the hot
waitress always works especially when
they touch your shoulder you think that
they love you for some reason I don't
man the laurels 8 is there anything else
you need I'm like you could have my
wallet my job where's the rest of my
ship there you go I just gotta tell you
to get it but not really
okay long time when I don't know what
I'm gonna do next
[Music]